the ci went into angola in july of 1975
we started out with six million dollars
and eventually the total budget was 31
million dollars south africa had
has still the most modern army on the
shores of africa so so of course they
felt like this was going to be a
cakewalk you know
they felt like that it was going to be
just a few weeks that they were going to
take rwanda then they were going to back
up and set up a united government
the mtla government asked for help sent
out a call for help and actually a lot
of countries came to help the major
countries cuba
[Music]
[Music]
very significant events occurred in
angola in 1988
where with the defeat of south african
troops by cuban and angolan forces
the whole balance of power in the area
has been altered
we're going to look at this
comprehensively with interviews and
sections from cuban documentaries
right now
on alternative views
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's been some very important
developments in south africa involving
angola south africa and other countries
in that region in attempts to create
peaceful settlements to some of the wars
that have been going on in that region
but you don't hear too much about this
from the u.s media well we're happy to
have with us today kenneth jones who's
on the national executive committee of
the venza ramos brigade who's been to
angola about a year ago and has
carefully studied affairs in that area
and it's going to give us an update on
current situation in angola and the
entirety of south africa
in addition to our interview with
kenneth jones we have extensive footage
which came from cuban television
documenting the military aspects and a
lot of the political aspects of the
operation in angola
we also have updates by john stockwell
former cia officer
who was instrumental in the activities
in 1975
with the cia in angola
for background information we'll take a
brief look at a documentary about john
called the cia case officer
by saul landau and haskell wexler
well let's start with our interview with
kenneth jones
the angolan revolution the the angola
reached independence in 1975
um and at that time there were three
organizations one was called the mpla
the movement
for the popular movement for the
liberation of angola the fnla and i'm
going to get these names straight in a
minute and
you need to
and all three were
fnla was operated pretty much in the
north you need to operate pretty much in
the south and the mpla operated
throughout the whole country
and at independence in november of 1975
south africa invaded now at this time
most people wasn't sure which
organization which group that they
supported but in 1975 when the mpla
which was the government when portugal
angola was a portuguese calling when
portugal pulled out
mpla formed a government
at that time also south africa invaded
from the south
um
zaire invaded from the north
with nair invaded from the north along
with fnla troops south africa invaded
from the south along with united troops
so this made it clear for most people
you know which was the true liberation
movement and the cia put a lot of funds
into it into angola the ci went into
angola in july of 1975 we started out
with six million dollars and eventually
the total budget was 31 million dollars
the first effort was arms that were sent
from america to kinshasa in u.s air
force c-141 planes
then from kinshasa we hauled the arms
into angolan smaller
the total was about 1 500 tons of arms
30 000 rifles and small rockets and
mortars our funds and arms were going to
two of the three angola factions one of
them headed up by holden roberto who had
had a relationship with us for about 15
years
and to savimbi who had not been well
known by the
he cia the sole virtue of being in
opposition to the npla and we were
determined to oppose president mubutsu
zaire wanted this program
we bribed him we gave him 2 million
hundred fifty thousand dollars
ci officers went in as advisers and
trainers they were called intelligence
gatherers but in fact uh they were
preparing our allies for combat
uh i fled to san salvador on january
16th
what did the enemy do in san salvador
you mean what i saw
with their own eyes they saw they were
americans
there were 20 americans
these americans what did they look like
were they white were they black
describe them
there were not enough ci advisors to
make a great deal of difference however
and we hired european mercenaries and we
tried to hire white angolan refugees to
go back in as mercenaries fighting on
our side
the cia collaborated with the south
africans and it was not officially
ordered by the national security council
but there was liaison at all levels the
cia was nervous about the role the
senate might play in this war senator
clark on the foreign relations committee
made a trip to africa to review the
situation backfiring the trip to report
to the senate
cia watched him
with some apprehension to see that he
didn't get information we didn't want
him to have
the senate led by senator clark shut
down the angola program in december of
75.
while the senate was shutting us down a
cuban army eventually of 10 to 15 000
combat soldiers made 21 aircraft tanks
just swept over the fnla in unita
and we lost decisively
the victory of the heroic people
of angola
cuba had a long history of support for
african liberation and i i don't want to
go into that it might take a little too
much time but they supported in the
congo with lumumba
they they they worked with different
groups in just all over africa in terms
of african liberation che guevara is
there working with some african
liberation
movements in fact a lot of cubans are
black that a lot of the cubans
originally were slaves who came over
from africa to work on the spanish sugar
cane plantations so they have roots
there and they still maintain the the
culture of the so-called mother country
the interesting thing is that i was
reading one thing it's really true they
said one of the most interesting
paradoxes of history is that if the
slave
traders knew
that that the people that they were
taking over
you know to cuba
to cut sugar cane as slaves were going
to come back centuries later and help
liberate that territory they would just
they wouldn't know what to do and that's
true you know but anyhow so they had
they had the situation is that that the
employee government is backed up into
the capital of luanda
there's uh two major armies one coming
from the south
you know south africa put one of the the
biggest tank brigades together since
world war ii you know to to attack and
also from the north now south africa had
has still the most modern army on the
shores of africa so so of course they
felt like this was going to be a
cakewalk you know uh they felt like that
it was going to be just a few weeks that
they were going to take rwanda then they
were going to back up and set up a
united government
the mtla government asked for help sent
out a call for help and actually a lot
of countries came to help the major
country was cuba they they they um they
discussed it and they decided that if if
south africa took angola that all of
africa would be would have to deal with
apartheid
and and and it would it would
destabilize more and more borders so the
african countries also supported cuba
coming that's just an important point to
make
so cuba sent over about 40 000 troops or
so
to stop the south african invasion
they um the south africans at this time
were right outside of rwanda but you
know before the cubans could come they
had done a tremendous amount of damage
you know to the angolan countryside
you know moving all the way up
cuban stopped them in the angle and
stopped them another important point is
that the the mpla army was a guerrilla
army which is totally i don't know if
your viewers um
are into
tactics of war but you don't hold man
when you're trying to try to hold lane
with your guerrilla armor it's a
different technique
so they they really didn't even know how
to do to to to fight the south african
desire and you need to nfla okay so so
the cuban army comes in um stops the
attack and pushes south africa all the
way back to the borders of namibia which
is pretty amazing a small country like
cuba taking a giant like south africa
which was supported by the cia in the
united states and pushing him back and
pushed their troops back to up to the
north and then the south africans
immediately wanted to negotiate and they
wanted to negotiate because they knew
that that the force that had been put
together could have went right into
namibia and liberated namibia then
but but but they they stopped at the
namibian border and negotiated south
africa said that they would stay there
should be a demilitarized zone on both
sides of the angolan border in namibia
and angola and that they would pull back
of course what happened was they didn't
they continually invaded they
continually invaded and kept invading up
till you know last year
so that that that that's the historical
situation and i can if you want talk
about some of the current um well that's
what we're interested in what's been
going on in the last year or two to try
to normalize yeah the the south africans
are saying they want to negotiate again
i wouldn't trust them right right
right on both points south africans want
to negotiate again and of course people
wonder why is that i mean why all of a
sudden the south africans want peace in
angola and
and also are ready to um uh sign the u.n
resolution 435 giving independence to
namibia which will sure put in a swap of
government southwest which is a leftist
government yeah and it's the government
today would have been trying to stop
since they have been in uh in namibia
well the point is this
in november of uh first of all south
africa has continually invaded and and
there have been how how the defense of
angola has been over since 75
is they have built up three lines of
defense the fnl i mean the um the poplar
troops which is the angolan army three
lines of defense and then behind them
the cubans are the cubans
sit back and have really have not really
been in battle since 75 76
yes uh the poplar troops you know are so
good now that they have been able to
stop south africa they the south african
troops have never been able to get to
the third line of defense the second
line has always stopped the south
african troops
but south africa decided that the
balance of forces were such that they
wanted because they were afraid that
that that swappo was going to get
independence from namibia and a lot of
things were happening around africa and
they were even destabilizing more
countries more oh mozambique they've
been tearing moses bleeding mozambique
to death exactly
their own contrast right all right and
they've been lesothos um you know
swaziland uh botswana they've been going
to all these countries you know at will
so they decided they see south africa
understands that that the most important
country in southern africa right now is
angola and they wanted to destabilize
angola more than any other country so
what they decided was they put their
hopes on um attacking a small town
which was the center of the mpla
military it was called quito canelo
and they were going to move the angolans
out of quito canelo
put unita in
and um which is headed by savimbe the
guy who's been to the united states
supported by the cia and south african
connections okay cia has been supporting
this
you know since before 75 right even
though he says he's a marxist which is
curious
whatever whoever he's talking to he says
that's what he is right he's a christian
he's a marxist he's this he you know
he's another
big opportunist okay as a matter of fact
that you know one of the things that
that's really clear is the cia and the
united states government support unita
through with a lot of funds and by
supporting unity they're supporting
south africa we can't decide without
asking south africans we can decide
without asking
the americans a lot of the weapons that
go to united end up in south african
hands anyhow they wanted to to to take
up this this town called quito connect
and make it a and you need a stronghold
and then you need it was going to
declare a government you know in and and
and then ask for south african help if
they were attacked so that was the plan
so it sounded like a very good plan so
they the south africans moved in across
the river queen canaval was on a river
and started bombarding and sieging
and this happened in november they the
siege was went from november to march
november of 87 to march of 88 there was
a siege they attacked the city at least
once a month with major attacks coming
in january february and march to try to
break
and push the mpla out of quito carnaval
the the angolans again asked the cubans
for assistance
because they realized that this was the
most
serious attempt at breaking their
sovereignty
that has happened since 75 so they asked
the cubans for help the cubans talked
about it and discussed it and decided
that it was so important that they not
take this time that they not only there
were about 40 000 cubic troops already
in angola that so that they not only
wanted to move those cuban troops into
battle but they sent 12 000 of their
best troops of their
that were in cuba to angola
this was a very complex undertaking
particularly from the logistics point of
view
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for this operation the cuban army will
only take volunteers
each person is interviewed to see if
they have any personal objections to
being a volunteer
or if they have any home problems or
psychological problems which would
prevent them from
volunteering
[Music]
the term internationalista is a very
special one in cuba
people who volunteer for
overseas duty of any type whether
military or health workers or education
are called internationalists
[Music]
the equipment was also brought to the
ports by rail
depot
the commanding general of the troops in
angola gives an orientation and
welcoming speech
the general reconfirms the voluntary
nature of the operation and asks if each
of the soldiers is a volunteer
an advanced contingent of troops is sent
over by airplane
these are people from the cuban special
forces
the bulk of the troops and their
equipment are sent by ship to angola
[Music]
the units of the special forces will be
sent to the action area where the
situation is most critical
at cuito carnevale itself
this is the area that the south africans
are attacking
and this is about 1 000 kilometers from
the
airport in luanda
next is the south african attack
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
these are the south african airplanes
[Applause]
and these are the cubans defending quito
carnival
[Music]
[Music]
these cuban mig airplanes in the hands
of the cuban pilots turned out to be
decisively superior to those of the
south africans
the only airport
in angola was at luanda there were three
ports however to receive the ships
the last two were in the southern part
of the country
still about a thousand kilometers
from the war zone itself
transporting the mana material to this
area was a herculean task
[Music]
the trek to the war zone begins
so so now there's 52 000 you know cuban
troops in angola they said they said and
fidel castro actually said that because
they sent these 12 000 troops it called
the the defenses of their own country
into question
they had
their defenses weren't as good because
they sent these 12 000 troops
it wasn't just the fact that the roads
in this
underdeveloped country were very
primitive
and very few
there were also losses and delays caused
by mined roads
those mines which were laid by savimbi's
forces
and also a lot of bridges had been blown
up by the gorillas and by the south
africans
and added to all this was the fact that
this was occurring during the spring
floods
and so a lot of bridges were washed out
as well as those which were demolished
and blown up by the
guerrilla forces
nonetheless the cubans did an amazing
job of fording all of these areas
bypassing some areas and where this was
impossible their engineers actually
repaired and rebuilt the bridges
themselves
another monumental task of engineering
and construction
was building an airstrip which was close
enough to the battle zone for a close
support tactical operations for the
troops
the construction was made well enough so
that it could be used well into the
future not just for the immediate needs
of the battle zone itself
by working around the clock the cubans
completed the airstrip in only six weeks
the cubans claimed that south africans
were caught off guard and surprised by
the short time it took for them to build
the airstrip
the cuban air power had a devastating
effect on the south africans
meanwhile back in havana fidel castro
was
examining every detail of what was going
on
and this scene he's talking to his
supply officer asking him where he's
getting the food they're buying angolan
tuna
and
also wondering about why there are so
many coals among the soldiers suggesting
that they should be sending more vitamin
c to the troops
castro also questioned very closely this
tank commander who just came back from
the battles
he suggests some changes in tactics
meanwhile
some of the soldiers who have arrived at
the war zone start preparing defensive
positions
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
my
[Music]
but also a political indoctrination as
to why they're there and what they're
supposed to be doing
meanwhile the soldiers wait
prepare their positions with the help of
some
automated equipment which builds the
trenches for them
they prepare their machinery
and get ready for battle
the woman who is the head of the medical
unit at the front says it's not only
important to have medical facilities
available but also it's good for morale
to have women there
are the facilities which the cubans have
for medical assistance and treatment
near the front
it's equivalent to our mass units in the
korean war
and here is what the patients would find
in a city
[Music]
before going into battle
the angola troops entertained the cuban
troops
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
from the end of january throughout
february the south africans attacked
trying to break the lines of the
angolans the phapla troops
which were east of quito carnival
[Music]
the heavy attacks by the south africans
caused severe losses to the angola
troops which at one time in one
significant sector only had eight tanks
left
to face the
south africans
but the angolans held particularly with
the help of the fresh cuban troops this
is vitally important because
the main thrust
of the cuban attack was going to be to
the west and to the south of the city to
meet the south africans at the namibian
border rather than passively receive the
south african attacks and then
counter-attack
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there was a lot of heavy fighting
from the end of january throughout
february
with south africa attacking several
times
and the cubans gradually pushing them
toward the south
the cubans particularly had the
advantage in detective
equipment such as radar sound detection
and also in control of the air
with the cuban planes vastly
outperforming those of the south
africans and driving them from the sky
as a result of this the south africans
changed their tactics
they could not make any day attacks
anymore because they had no air
superiority or a chance of surprise
so they started launching a series of
night attacks
the south africans still figured they
had technological superiority and so
they attacked repeatedly in february
in one such attack
the south africans began
at four in the morning
attacking the fopla troops
on the flank of the cubans trying to
turn the flank and driving a wedge
between them
but the attack was beaten off throughout
this battle which lasted more than 12
hours
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the commander of the cuban troops in
angola
reviewed the situation the next day
with his battle weary troops
can be seen in their steps and in their
faces
still believing they had superior
equipment the south africans continued
to attack into march
they did have excellent artillery and
that was causing the cubans and the
angolan some problems
the south africans thought that their
tanks were superior to those of the
cubans but this turned out not to be the
case
[Music]
as the lines held at quito
the cubans angolans and swapo troops
pushed to the south
toward the libyan border
and into that country
at the same time they also
attack south africa on two other fronts
you know quinto carnaval is more in the
um eastern part in the western part they
also attack and and the army consisted
of which is a very good army now
of the cuban troops of swapo the
liberation organization in namibia and
the anc the liberation organization in
south africa so actually what you had
was a
liberation army of a number of countries
a number of liberation movements and
countries
coming together to defeat apartheid in
south africa
the leader of swapo the namibian
resistance had this to say in a speech
suapo and its military wing the people's
liberation army of namibia plan
has created confidence
in the masses of the namibian people
that they are self-liberators so their
struggle will be intensified until all
the forces of fascism colonialism as
represented in our country by the both
regimes are wiped out and this is our
power becomes a reality in namibia
they push it all the way back to the
namibian border and again south africa
wanted to negotiate but this time it was
even a it was more of a major defeat
than last time and the reason is that
cuba brought over and angola had um
something called mid-23s these are these
jets that uh south africa the soviet
union you know um gave to cuba well
actually cuba bottom and and also angola
bought some they were known the the migs
the the um
the mirage jets that that south africa
bought from france were no match for
these the south africa also had these
really big tanks that they call
elephants these elephant tanks scare
people because they're really big and
they're really loud but they are no
match for the smaller more accurate
soviet tanks so they were picking off
tanks like that you got into a soviet i
mean a south african tank that was like
a death wish just like a
mirage jet it was a death vision because
there was no way that you could you
could you could you could live so so
they were knocking on all
of south africa's major weapon systems
what happened in this battle was that
south africa also attacked with what's
called the namibian territorial militia
that these are black troops that south
africa was using as cannon fodder these
troops rebelled
and refused to fight because they
realized what what the deal was
so south africa had to move up its white
troops
and so what south africa was began to to
have to to deal with is a lot of white
troops were getting killed their planes
were getting knocked out of the sky they
couldn't even send up a plane um the
troops were getting beat really bad so
the white south africans were getting
killed by the you know you know dozens
their scores or whatever and um
so
and the interesting thing was that all
of a sudden within south africa a a um a
resistance movement began to develop for
the draft people began to say i am not
going into the army sounds like the
united states and vietnam where
particularly black and hispanic soldiers
got fed up you know fighting and dying
over in vietnam
american jets were getting shot off by
vietnamese rifles etc and so the war
just couldn't continue right and so it's
the same thing going on in south africa
right so so on the one hand you have
which is a very important point i'd like
to make you have south africa in namibia
attacking angola and south africa has
made namibia the most militarized area
you know along the border the most
militarized area in the world there are
more weapons more guns more tanks more
more missiles in the world right in that
northern part of namibia
so of course they felt like they were
going to um just just again take this
town and it would be very easy but the
important thing for your viewers to
understand is that the balance of forces
in southern africa have totally changed
now south africa cannot go around with
impunity and not expect to to get get
beat
in may of 1988 fidel castro addressed
the special meeting of the non-aligned
countries on the importance of quito
carnival
but i may assure you something
important the history of africa will
happen
[Music]
the intelligent power
and there's a serious hope that there
will be a negotiated settlement to the
problems of southern africa and that
south africa will at least be put in its
place for the time being and we'll just
have to see if this is a ruse or if
they're forced
into scaling back in their operations
every time there's been a peace
agreement or peace discussions with
south africa south africa has used it it
that that that discussion to move more
troops and to re-arm
and so what's happening now is south
africa is trying to find a way
to uh to rearm itself
and get more modern weapons so they can
go back into angola everybody knows that
everybody and so what they're trying to
do is use this cuban troops issue as a
guise to do that
and you know the angolas and the cubans
know what's happening because they've
fought south africa before but because
of this major defeat it causes a very
big problem for south africa because
they're going to have to either
negotiate or fight and they can't win by
fighting so they're going to have to
negotiate does south africa want to
negotiate
why is it that south africa wants to
negotiate
south africa wants to negotiate
because it is fighting a very strong
force
he had never clashed before as he had
never encountered before nowhere
this is not the year 1975
1975 we had 4 400
[Music]
but we
we have accumulated around here as many
times more or less as south africa has
but they are better
we are not
working to obtain
a military victory we don't want to have
a military victory
it's enough if you
and any military glory really faith
because we feel responsible for the life
of each and every of those men there
and
otherwise it wouldn't be a settlement
from fidel castro's opinions from may of
1988 and kenneth jones of december of 88
we turned to john stockwell in february
of 1989. john's book in search of
enemies is primarily about angola
south africa is so-called getting out of
angola
but they did before
and then they came right back in again
when there was
looked like there were going to be peace
in the area
now
looks like the same thing happened they
had they're getting the cubans to pull
out they got their ears pinned back
they pulled away
but now i understand that i heard where
they've actually made some more armed
attacks already
three three weeks ago in london in the
interviews and discussions
this is very much what we were talking
about was was uh what is the guarantee
that south africa is going to respect
this the cubans pull out
south africa pulls out what's going to
keep south africa
violating every
international law and boundary in
southern africa what's going to keep
them from going back into angola how
long will it be before they put their
troops back and the answer was two weeks
yeah
and now interestingly enough
washington's reaction on this of course
reagan had a
a big aid program to savimbi and um
bush has promised to continue it and
obviously is clearly doing so now
savimbi's pinned down on the border down
there now
uh militarily uh and and is a little
better off than the countries are and he
was taking a beating so the south
african forces came in to bail him out
the u.s
uh response they obviously didn't stand
up and say well we happen to be in there
in force with the cia and we call the
south africans in
their their statement was i can just
remember you know bagging the task force
scribbling away the wording on the
statement you know when you were running
when we were running
their their answer was that it has not
been confirmed
by any reliable sources that the south
africans are in fact back in angola they
are in fact tell our audience that john
stockwell was the cia
officer in charge of the angola
operation and resigned after that wrote
his book in search of enemies that began
his process of developing a criticism of
the cia and has been speaking out as a
peace activist
ever since so angola has basically been
a hot point
for the whole reagan administration well
let's strip angola down just real
briefly while we're on the subject
chester crocker
assistant secretary of state for african
affairs
was talking to some of us in the
africanist
progressive side of things jerry bender
particulate the international school at
usc
and promising that he was going to
negotiate a settlement for namibia and
get the cubans out of angola
and jerry who my a friend whom i respect
enormously said that you know if you
succeed we'll give you credit for it
publicly
and crocker succeeded he pounded away
and negotiated a way and it took six
years and eventually he worked out a
deal where the south africans would give
namibia its independence and the cubans
would go home
and the cubans are going home and it's a
real deal and the south africans are you
know there is
at least some kind of a farcical
independence being given to namibia
the oversight is it going to work are
the u.n forces going to cover it are
death squads going to be left behind to
keep a proxy control you know that
question remains but still
bender and and i supporting him were
obliged to say yes you know crocker you
did you did it
now maybe it finally is getting its
independence however
in that fascinating complex deal the
cubans are coming home south africa is
giving independence to namibia
and and getting out of angola and
promising to stay out even but the
united states although arbitrating that
thing did not promise to cease its aid
to savimbi to destabilize angola now
that is brass
but it's also just idiotic i mean it
just it sort of confirms your thesis in
search of enemies that the role of the
cia is to search out enemies to fight
wars to destabilize the world here's a
region that needs stability there's
negotiations to try to stabilize it and
the u.s keeps supporting
these rebel forces to try to overthrow
the angola government that led to the
all the absolutely bizarre situation of
the cubans there that were supporting
the soviet-backed angolan government
protecting the u.s multinational
corporations i think gulf well had big
four which was brought up by chevron the
cubans were protecting against the
cia-backed angolan rebel forces so
there's no it's not even in u.s economic
interests when
was brought to washington in the winter
of 86 remember he he
uh he was he was he dined at the white
house and yet he went on television
promising the aid that he was being
given that he would attack gulf oil
facilities which facilities had been
built by loans which reagan had approved
in addition to which he has kept the
central part of angola frozen and the
benguela railroad shot and that's zaire
our big clients only economically viable
egress to the sea is that railroad that
we pace of envy to keep shut meanwhile
the human horror the red cross counts 55
000 people in angola who have been
maimed by saving these land mines and
attacks and george bush continues to
support those forces john
one of the analyses that i heard about
the the situation was that there was
pressure within south africa
to get out they wanted to get out of the
angolan situation
they didn't want to
support it financially and also there
were problems because their soldiers
were getting killed so the united states
said okay go ahead pull out will come in
and will directly supervise the
situation and take care of it so it
wasn't a big victory for the angola
government or for cuba in that respect
it was just a switch of
people who were going to control it well
this yeah this is exactly the point i
was trying to make is that uh us crocker
playing big arbitrator and we didn't
agree to give the region peace but it is
a fact that namibia is getting its
independence
the the south africa is going to try to
do what we did to nicaragua in 1933 when
we pulled the marines out and created
the guard and left it behind with samosa
you know in charge they're trying to
create the same type of a situation and
have a proxy control of it
from the cuban point of view
the angolans are are being left facing a
dire situation with savine be still
being funded to destabilize and the
south africans still coming across the
border
and the cubans coming home and in cuba's
uh interests and and it's it's very
difficult to fault them because they've
uh
they sacrificed a lot of their own and
their own capital to the extent that
they can and they're not a wealthy
country
to stick up for their allies the
angolans but this is the point at which
they could in fact come home
with uh
having accomplished you know a
measurable objective that is namibia is
independent because of what they did yet
the independence of namibia or any
country in africa is precarious because
of the cia presence there whenever an
independent african nation
takes a socialist road or a road that
goes against the interests or ideologies
of the cia they destabilize the
government kwami and kruma wrote a book
called class struggles in africa that
documented the ways that the cia
overthrew about 25 progressive
governments in
africa including in chroma's own
ghandian government in the 1960s so if
nabibia takes a route that the cia
doesn't like they can act to destabilize
it one way or the other so that's really
the precarious situation that all
independent nations in africa face
this is one of chomsky's best points is
that when the u.s when a country tries
to escape
our first effort is to bludgeon them
back into the fold and if that fails
as it did in cuba conspicuously as it
did in vietnam conspicuously as it's
done in angola to date
and nicaragua to date then the fallback
is to starve them out
create economic chaos so that they will
not be a positive example to anyone else
to want to break free
we don't want to have a military victory
it's enough if you want if you haven't
gloria victoria and any military glory
really fades
because we feel responsible for the life
of each and every of those men there
we are striving
for a fair solution to the problem
a dignified solution to the problem
which would guarantee the security
the conditions so that a settlement can
be received
otherwise
is
disarmament south africa will have no
other choice
such a settlement is attained the time
to demand from south africa to discuss
with the
settlement
agency
the problem of apartheid
of course south africa knows that it is
in a situation of danger
because all those forces
they have never had to face social
republicans
and south africa very calculating
cynical opportunity
if we can do something and get away with
it
if they could go into muslims they would
do it
if they can go into zambia they do it to
do anything to commit crimes
if it
have to face such an important forces
the concentration of cuban and golden
forces there now they think it twice
they try to calculate the risks and they
are careful they are watchful and that's
real reality
and they know that they are in the face
of a risk
and it will be up to them
if they re if they react
with a happiness and if they want to
come forward
it could happen
military
one of the great problems remaining to
africa not only to africa but to the
world at large but even if the south
africans and the cubans all leave angola
that still leaves savimbi free in the
country still supported by the united
states
john stockwell tells us more about
savimbi
south africa's policy is to keep angola
destabilized
they've kept their armies in southern
angola for about 10 years since the 75
thing
they've costed billions of dollars in
damages they raid and bomb throughout
you know up into the central part of the
country
with the purpose of you know just
keeping the country off balance and
keeping it at war and keeping it from
being able to spend its money to build
schools and hospitals
and they've supported savimbi
because he can he can work with his
guerrilla forces and go in and raid and
blow things up deep into the country so
they've armed him and fed him and kept
him viable
well superficially you know this is very
appealing this guy is
macho plus he is very charismatic he's a
beautiful guy he's fun he's got these
kind of wide popping eyes and his energy
you know and he's he's got a quality
which very few of these liberation
leaders have
which is he likes to fight he likes to
be in the bush with his men
and and you know everywhere else in the
world the trouble like the country
commanders they want to be in
tagucigalpa or in miami and they don't
want to go in there and die in the hills
of northern nicaragua they want to get
in maya in managua and drive the
mercedes
but savimbi wants to be in there with
his men directing the things and you
know him well you spent time with him i
guess didn't you i went into his lair
and
recruited him into our program and then
indirectly managed the liaison with him
that charisma and his like you know is
his his yen for the the contest
and he's fighting communists a marxist
government and man that's simple we have
to support him we have a moral
obligation to support him wow let's give
him some money now it gets a little bit
more wrinkly when you add in the fact
that savimbi isn't about marxist
portuguese colonialists under a marxist
maoist banner in the last year
we've we've had sabine be going on
television and telling about his plans
if he ever gets into power to reorganize
the country along marxist lines
now what we're doing and we've given him
the first 15 million dollars to savimbi
and we've got trainers in there with him
right now
to to train him in his terrorist
activities and this is the man we would
go in and work with
now the congressman and senators that i
was talking to would say well what are
our alternatives and i was saying that's
easy we establish relations with the
government of angola which is what golf
and rockefeller and everybody have been
saying all along to provide the
diplomatic umbrella and influence for
our corporations that are doing great
business there right now
and then
we order south africa to get her troops
out of the country because they have a
policy of destabilizing this country
and of course we shut off aid to savimbi
and hopefully starve him out so that he
has a choice of working
peacefully politically in the country
which may be impossible now because
there's so much bloodshed but it was
possible originally or he can go live
somewhere else and and play some other
game
what is the
response of the rest of the world toward
angola you know what is in 97 percent of
the world condemns this it's we're on
the wrong side for us to be
holding hands with and working with
south africa and the brutalization of a
black african country is
criminal and just totally in politic
and that's alternative views for this
time
we have a lot of people to thank for our
program right now
our camera person was our eq bank audio
man kevin l west our editor was christy
swear and of course austin community
television ac tv
some other people contributed greatly
maria elena martinez provided us with
the interview
charles knaphis gave us the copy of the
cuban television
documentaries and haskell wexler and
saul landau let us use their documentary
on john stockwell
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network po box
7279 austin texas 78713